مشهد يشبه الى حد كبير مشهد حشد القوات
الروسيه على الحدود الاوكرانيه لتشتعل
الحرب بعدها
تاهب قتلى كامل على الحدود بين صربيا
واقليم كوسوفو في تصعيد جديد من نوعه بعد
ان امر الرئيس الصربي الكسندرفوتشيتش بوضع
القوات الصربيه في حاله التاهب ليرتفع عدد
الجنود من 10500 جندي حاليا الى خمسه الاف
بلغراد تتذرع بمخاوف تسليح الالباني
كوسوفو متمسكه بحمايه المواطنين في صربيا
بعد نشر وسائل الاعلام اخبار عن شنه هجوم
على المناطق الصربيه شماليه
لكننا سنبذروا قصار جهدنا وسنحرص على حفظ
السلام والاستقرار ليس ذلك فحسب بل سنعمل
على حمايه شعبنا في شمال كوسوفو هي بعد
تسليح البانيو كوسوفو ورفع استعدادهم
القتاليه ساتخذ جميع الاجراءات الضروريه
لحمايه شعبنا وحمايه صربيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي للتهدئه وعدم الاتجاه
نحو التصعيد تتجاهلها بالجراد لكن الكتله
الاوروبيه حذرت من اي عواقب لعمل عسكري
اما برستينا فلم ترد على مزاعم الهجوم على
صرب كسوفه الا انها كانت قد اتهمت الرئيس
الصربي بممارسه الالعاب بهدف اثاره
المتاعب
توترات هي والده سنوات طويله من النزاع
بين الطرفين الا ان الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا زادت من مخاوف اثاره البركان شبه
الغامد بين صربيا وكوسوفو لتكون ابسط
الشرارات التي ظهرت مؤخرا كالقاء القبض
على شرطي سابق من قبل سلطات كوسوفو وتحديد
بريشتينا موعد الانتخابات المحليه
كفيله باشعال نار الحرب اذا عمر العربيه